since it first hit the air in 1999
family guy has delivered hundreds of
episodes packed with insane antics and
crazy cutaways so much has happened
since its debut we thought it would be a
good time to look back and recap some
classic moments from family guy's first
season at some point in the show meg
went from the slightly odd and neglected
child of the family to default punching
back it's a shame because she's a fun
character and is now expertly brought to
life by the talented mila kunis but that
wasn't always the case most people know
that meg was originally voiced by lacey
chabert famous for her work on mean
girls and party of five but a mistake in
her contract and the desire to focus on
school as well as party of five found
her leaving shortly after the first
season this is hard for some to have
spotted as chabert isn't even credited
on most episodes she's in but the
actress is said to have left on good
terms even more women have been tied to
the character some were brought in on
special episodes to provide meg's
singing voice like tara strong for
example as well as a couple that never
made it to air show creator seth
macfarlane's sister rachel mcfarlane who
would go on to a starring role in
american dad portrayed meg in the
original pilot episode but what may
surprise some is that voice acting
legend cree summer was originally given
the job to the point of even recording
lines for episodes before being replaced
meg got swapped around a lot in the
early days but she is still given a few
shining moments in that first season
the show that would eventually become
family guy almost began in several
different forms one of which would have
been a segment on mad tv and another
version was aimed at a younger audience
what ended up becoming the first episode
of the series we all know today needed
to introduce the audience to the entire
griffin family and get the audience on
board with a clueless father a talking
dog and a vengeful verbose baby the
episode death has a shadow focuses a bit
more on peter and doesn't try to be
subtle early in the episode his defense
to keep lois from uncovering his lies is
to call her fat he loses his job due to
drinking 37 beers and brian hits him on
the head with a newspaper like he's the
bad dog all of this is in the first half
of the episode from there peta becomes
welfare rich flies a blimp over the
super bowl and lands in jail it's a lot
quite the journey for a main character
in a first outing the episode's central
conflict is finally resolved thanks to
stewie's mind control device but only
after the kool-aid man burst through a
wall oh yeah
the second episode i never met the dead
man holds a memorable moment for many
die hard fans one that lands somewhere
between ingenuity and insanity for those
who have forgotten that far back it's
peter's fault that the town has no cable
television and meg is taking the blame
for the incident to cope with not being
able to occupy his time in front of the
tube peter gets creative and crafts his
own set out of household scraps what
most might not remember about this
particular episode is that it features
the series first big celebrity cameo not
just for an opening gag or flashback and
the initial clue fans were given about
mcfarland's love of star trek peter
begins paddling around with none other
than william shatner the og captain kirk
himself unfortunately this is only a
visual cameo because shatner didn't
voice the character still it's great to
see the two interact but thanks to
stewie's weather machine makes
distracted driving takes out the show's
first real gas star my god i hit william
shatner
light growing dimmer can't breathe beam
me up god
throughout the series everyone seems to
abuse mick it's a staple of family guy
so it isn't too surprising when the
young gryffindor gets excited to make a
new friend jennifer even if she is a
little odd and too bubbly this new
friend compliments meg unlike the
cheerleaders and even invites her to
meet other people their age it seems
like a wonderful situation all around
even if the boys in the group are all
castrated meg's either so happy to have
people to finally hang out with or just
really slow but either way she misses
all of the clues that this new group
she's found is a cult the blue jumpsuit
crew is setting up to all drink some
punch and die together but thankfully
peter shows up and unwittingly saves his
daughter the kicker at the end is
peter's last line to meg after the rest
of the kids all dispose of themselves
off screen
sorry meg i guess that's another bunch
of people who'd rather fake their own
death than go to a party with you stewie
griffin is a complex individual
especially after several years of
development but he was a little easier
to follow when the character was simply
a baby evil genius in the first season
sure his oddly shaped head and
mysterious british accent might make him
seem eccentric and out of place but it's
the wild inventions and diabolical plots
that make him such a joy in those early
episodes fans will hear the full name of
this character a handful of times
throughout the series but most have
forgotten it or at least that we learned
it so early on in chitty chitty death
bang stewie's plans to fly to nicaragua
and raise an army as well as have an
in-flight happy meal are throated when
the airport staff believes him to be a
lost little boy at that point it's a
one-way trip to a security office where
the infant believes he's about to be
interrogated and that the officer works
for his enemy after an airport security
guard attempts to understand him and
offers some sound advice about growing
up stewie reveals his middle name by
stating defiantly stuart gilligan
griffin runs from nothing the evil
genius comes out a little more after
that when he thanks the guard by
freezing him and carbonite
peter griffin gets into a lot of fights
especially with ernie the giant chicken
over the years we've seen the family guy
lose his temper for various reasons and
throw down with little thought given to
his own well-being the fourth episode of
season one mind over murder shows a
great example of how his impulsive
actions get him into a ton of trouble
but this particular incident has
possibly aged the worst out of any of
the main story gags in the initial run
peter is upset that another parent is
speaking ill of his son chris calling
him moby dick among other things so
peter decides to let his frustration out
the only way he knows how with a punch
it takes a minute for peter to realize
he's hit a woman even though everyone is
calling her one the gravity of the
situation doesn't fully sink in until
she gives birth on the sidelines it's a
big plot point at the beginning of the
episode and returns later for a quick
bit but not until after peter sends her
a gift that makes things even worse
many shows resort to time travel but
that's usually when the stories are
drying up and the show has jumped the
shark family guy decided to deploy it in
its fourth episode just in case the
first three hadn't cemented that there
were no rules typical to the show's
humor time travel would be used later on
to tell full stories and set up bigger
events but in its first appearance the
science fiction element simply serves to
undo all of peter's mistakes it all
began with the teething baby stewie who
figured the best way to fight the pain
would be to speed up time things
progressed as expected on family guy
with peter punching a pregnant woman
being put on house arrest and choosing
to build a bar in his basement instead
of spending time with lois this sets up
an issue with his wife and other local
housewives who think she's taking the
attention of their men this part is also
peter's fault by singing to them at the
bar to top it off quagmire gets bored
and accidentally starts a fire on his
way out of the establishment this all
leads to stewie's time machine saving
the house from burning down by turning
back the clock and altering the past of
course this does nothing to help with
stewie's dental issues
oh my teeth
i'm free free
i claim this mouth in the name of
incisor
out of all of peter's friends joe
swanson is arguably the most interesting
of the bunch he's a superb athlete
police officer a father and a husband to
an almost constantly pregnant woman
bonnie joe does all of this as a man in
a wheelchair a fact that is hidden until
the big company softball game in his
debut episode joe is regarded as a legit
hero one who seems to get everything
right and has plenty of stories to tell
but the main one he shares in the fifth
episode a hero sits next door is the
origin of how he lost his mobility it
was a snowy christmas eve in the big
city and some presents had been stolen
from a local orphanage officer swanson
had climbed to a rooftop to find a
figure with a large sack but this
particular intruder looks familiar to
everyone as the grinch the two fought
atop the snow-covered roof and just as
joe thought he'd retrieved the
children's presence the fiendish grinch
through a skate tripping up joe and
sending him off the building the fall
paralyzed him but he found the strength
to give a christmas present to an orphan
still stewie isn't impressed with the
story and just wants to take over joe's
wheelchair oh enough if you won't share
your technological schemata with me
peaceably i shall take the information
from you by fourth wow looks like you
have a fan
lois has an odd past but most of those
aspects aren't revealed until later on
in the series and only in little bits
before things like her wealthy family or
illicit affair with a member of kiss
were brought up fans mostly saw her as
the consummate housewife the person who
had to shop cook clean and take care of
the kids but like the rest of her family
she's not perfect and we get a hint of
this in the first season and the sun
also draws there's a convoluted plot
centered on chris being kicked out of
the boy scouts that sends the family on
a road trip that of course goes awry and
they end up at an indian casino giving
lois the chance to gamble and become
addicted it all happens quite fast and
sets up the conflict for the second half
of the episode after lois betson loses
the car stranding the family at the
casino the rest of the episode deals
with peter's scheme to get their
property back this sends the father and
son duo on a vision quest with no food
but lois's addiction is overlooked for
the rest of the episode minus a brief
scene when they return also for some
reason peter hallucinates and receives
sage advice from an unexpected source
hey yo griffin
the fart hey
in the final episode of the first season
the griffins have to deal with a heat
wave and a broken air conditioner which
means that peter needs money fast he
reads about a local dog show and figures
that winning it might be the answer to
his problems brian's against the idea
but does it for the family he aces the
obstacle course but stops during the
final test begging for his treat his
refusal to perform this last trick in an
attempt to keep his dignity upsets peter
and is the catalyst for a huge argument
between the two these issues get more
complicated after brian is picked up by
the police for not having his license or
a leash this is when the audience learns
where actually brian came from peter
reminds him that he was astray and the
resulting flashback reveals more about
their first meeting
brian was homeless waiting at a
stoplight and cleaning windshields for
spare change peter feels bad for the
talking animal and invites him home for
dinner which was the beginning of their
long friendship after we learn about
brian's origin story things get even
worse for the family dog he eventually
ends up homeless again and locked up in
the pound of course by the end of the
episode he makes up with the griffin
family and he lets peter know how he
really feels about him
if you ever tell anyone about that i
will kill you
since this is family guy where
continuity isn't necessarily the
ultimate goal we should point out that
brian's backstory has changed a couple
times throughout the series which is
fine with us because we get more scenes
of him as a puppy check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you